le mois d'octobre a débuté avec la
disparition d'un grand chanteur charles
aznavour est décédé le 1er octobre
inhumé au cimetière de montfort l'amaury
l'artiste repose dans le caveau familial
ils étaient nombreux à lui faire un
dernier adieu c'est toute ma jeunesse 1
c'est un grand monsieur coin et la
génération d'un moment qu'il l'aimait
beaucoup
autre disparition d'une figure de la
télé philippe gildas est décédé le 28
octobre à l'âge de 82 ans
l'une de ses dernières apparitions
étaient sur tv 78 elle a fait t elle
cette année son quart de siècle la fête
des vendanges
elle est organisée à la ferme mousseau
le premier dimanche d'octobre par les
amis du passé d'elancourt depuis 25 ans
c'est une première dans l'histoire du
club de baseball les cougars de montigny
le bretonneux sont arrivés en finale
nationale du championnat de france de
division 1
rodolphe le meur leurs entraîneurs
étaient en plateau
ça fait 30 ans que le club existe on
fait en plus l'anniversaire 7 cette
année et ça tombe à point nommé
d'atteindre ce niveau d'être en finale
de ce championnat de division octobre
2018 pierre bédier s'en souviendra il a
été élu président de la fédération des
républicains des yvelines avec près de
59 % des suffrages face à alexandra
dublanche vice-présidente de la région
autre annonce en politique charline
avenel 40 ans a été nommée nouvelle
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
elle a d'ailleurs effectué son premier
déplacement le 6 novembre au collège les
molières des essarts le roi ce mois de
novembre est impacté par une forte
mobilisation qui ne vous a pas échappé
celle des gilet jaune
les français opposés à la hausse des
taxes sur les carburants ont bloqué le
pays notamment le samedi 17 novembre
depuis des années des années les
salaires y sont bloquées il songe les
mêmes ils diminuent alors aujourd'hui on
travaille on travaille toujours plus
mais c'est pour gagner moins
alors là du coup il y en a ras-le-bol
cette année marque également la fin du
centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale tout au long des commémorations
des yvelinois ont participé à des
opérations autour du souvenir de la
grande guerre côté sport déjà couronné
de quatre titres de champion de france
de tumbling axel duriez a brillé au
championnat du monde par groupe d'âge
2018 organisé en novembre à
saint-pétersbourg ce jeune des
clayes-sous-bois est le premier français
à être titré champion du monde de la
discipline dans la catégorie 13 14 ans
ne rien laisser passer fin novembre un
portail de signalement des violences
sexuelles a été lancée au commissariat
de guyancourt des ministres et des
secrétaires d'état étaient présents pour
l'occasion
quand vous êtes témoin d'un cambriolage
vous appelez la police ou la gendarmerie
quand vous avez connaissance d'une
violences sexistes et sexuelles votre
devoir de citoyen c'est d'appeler la
police ou la gendarmerie où désormais de
vous connecter à cette plate forme de
signalement des violences sexistes et
sexuelles et didier fischer a pris
officiellement le dimanche 9 décembre
ses nouvelles fonctions de maire de
coignières autre nomination jean noël
barrot nommé secrétaire général du modem
le 13 décembre la colère des lycéens
s'est fait entendre en ce mois de
décembre ils se sont mobilisés contre la
réforme du baccalauréat et de parcours
sub certaines mobilisations ont dégénéré
avec des heurts entre jeunes et forces
de l'ordre qui ont procédé à quatorze
interpellations il faut bien faire la
part des choses entre les lycéens qui
ont certaines revendications et des
individus qui viennent et qui profitent
de ces rassemblements pour venir casser
brûler des véhicules et attaqué les
forces de l'ordre dans le cadre de
l'aménagement du futur quartier la gare
de la ligne 18 50 ans est un dévoiement
de la rd 91 est prévu un projet qui
inquiète
un collectif d'habitants de
voisins-le-bretonneux
l'année s'est achevée avec les
festivités de noël c'était la première
édition du comptoir de noël au domaine
de madame elisabeth à versailles le fait
main est loin d'être dépassée pour noël
le do it yourself était à la mode en
cette fin d'année partons direction la
chine
à la tombée de la nuit des sculptures
lumineuses géantes illumine les jardins
du zoo de thoiry
à découvrir jusqu'au 10 mars